Although the maternal and paternal lines trace
different chromosomes, they both converge on the same
notion of human evolution. All modern humans
share a common ancestor from Africa. Now with
early humans populated Africa and migrated up
the coast, to the north east. An event
of the Great Human Expansion resulted in
the human exit to the Eurasian continents and
the eventual colonization of Oceania and lastly
the Americas. Over a period of 40
thousand years, humans migrated and colonized new
areas. And at every step of the way,
each founder population had significantly reduced genetic
variation compared to the original larger populations from
which they migrated. Now we talked about this effect in lesson six. So I want
you to tell me, what is this founder effect
caused by? I want you to pick one of the
following answers. And remember, that what we're talking about
here is the transition as humans go from Africa outwards,
each time they colonize a region. It's only a
subset of humans that colonize, so the gene pool is
a little bit smaller for that given population. As
they grow out, it expands again but then a new
region is colonized. And so you have a smaller group. Which
of the following do you think most appropriately applies to that?